سجلتوني كروس هدفا وصنعه اخر لياقوده ريال
مدريد للفوز بهدفين لواحد على قديش في
ختام المنافسات المرحله الرابعه عشر من
الدوري الاسباني لكره القدم يوم الخميس
وهي اخر مباراه قبل التوقف اذان انطلاق
مونديال قطر وفي غيابك للبنزيما الذي لا
يزال يشعر بالام في الفخذ افتتح الريال
التسجيل في الدقيقه ال 40 عندما وضع عيد
الميلتا والكره في الشباك براسه وضاعف
كروس النتيجه بتسديده قويه مباشره في
الدقيقه 70
في الدقيقه 88 بواسطه لوكاسبيرونس وبهذه
النتيجه
الى 50 نقطه في المركز الثاني ويوصل الضغط
على المتصدر برشلونه الذي فاز الثلاثاء
خارج الديار امام اوسنا ولا تفصله الا
نقطه مع ريال مدريد اما قد ايش فيظل في
المركز قبل الاخير برصيد 11 نقطه وفي
مباراتين اخرين يوم امس فاذا فالنسيا على
ريال بيتيس بثلاثيه نظيفه
تعادل رايو فايكانو مع سيلتا فيغو بدون
اهداف